hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game from round nine of the
2013 candidates tournament it's a game
between Peter Svidler and Alexander
Grigio now when I was deciding which
games to show from round nine I really I
really didn't know how to decide because
they're all really really excellent so I
decided to show all of them and this is
the game that we're gonna start with
because in my opinion it's the most
exciting game and it could very well be
the most exciting game of the entire
tournament but we still have a couple
you know a couple of rounds to go
definitely room for negotiations there
and before we actually see this game we
do have unfortunately only one photo and
it's a photo of Peter Svidler showing
something to John Sanders we don't have
any more photos before the game and if
you're interesting interested feel free
to pause the video here and try to
figure out what is it that Peter Svidler
who could be showing John Saunders that
would interest him so much so yeah and
we don't have another photo of rich but
the deaths from the press conference
after the game not a lot of players made
it to the press conference in round 9 as
they did have to take drug tests so
let's see this game similar has the
white pieces and he opens with d4 we
have a knight to f6 and c4 let me just
take care of that sound yeah okay I
always forget that g6 saw the Kings
Indian defense Knight to c3 Bishop to g7
efore d6 and they're like in his game
against trouble we have f3 the semi
variation of the Kings Indian defense we
have castles the Bishop to e3 c5 Knight
G to e2 Knight to c6 d5
when knife to e5 this is all very
standard Knight to g3 now h5 preparing
h4 to take away the night membership to
e2 issue does push h4 Knight to f1 and e
6 we have f4 and this is the critical
moment in the game so here probably you
want to play something like Knight to g4
as your knight is attacked you want to
attack White's a dark square Bishop here
and here white will decide either you
he will move the bishop or he will
decide to give up his light square
bishop either way you're you're winning
you're winning the bishop pair here but
this is what Grisha prepared in this
position Grif did not move the knight
back or even go Knight to g4
instead he prepared Knight captures on
c4 and it's I mean this is when you see
a move like this this is basically a
slap in the face as this move this
position was on the board and many times
by many players and it's the first time
anyone ever played Knight captures on c4
maybe not the first time but first time
in serious Grandmaster competition and I
believe it was a Gary Kasparov who said
after this game that during the nineties
he did consider this Knight captures on
c-4 move but he never actually played it
so okay Bishop captures on c4 there's
really no better move to to make here
and now comes b5 and already White has
to make make a decision does he want to
grab more material for now he has a
piece for a pond as he wants to doesn't
want to grab another pawn you know if
you're a head in material in you don't
really want too much material if you
don't have to take it but here if you
move if you move back then before it's
coming then your knight gets misplaced
and then the e4 pawn you lose that as
well and now our Black has two points
for the piece and you can't really even
call this a sacrifice black black but
it's probably even better here so after
this b5 we have as Knight is the
guarding d4 pawn bishop capture some b5
and E capture some d5 we have E 5 and D
captures on e5 you you could push d4
immediately but first the D captures on
e5 getting rid of your double bond and
the d4 is always a threat we have F
captures on e5 and now Bishop to g4 so
for Greece Chuck who really came
prepared into this game this is nothing
new to him he had this position on the
board in his home preparation he had
Bishop g4 attacking the Queen and now
it's up this wheeler who who sees this
position for the first time to figure
out what he wants to do here and how to
handle this position now your queen is
attacked you probably want to do
something about
so so how do you how do you do it well
there are there are many different ideas
here for example if you go Queen to d2
then black can always simply push d4
attack your knight attack your bishop
and after you capture black can capture
and with your king stuck anyone this
bishop is slicing all the way here you
can't run away with the King you can't
develop this Knight the Queen is
blocking it the bishop is blocking it
you can develop it to g3 the H pawn is
blocking it black maybe maybe an engine
could withstand this attack but but no
human over the board while the clock is
ticking good so definitely not something
you want to do after Bishop to g4 you
could consider Queen a4 with the idea of
maybe capturing the night and then Queen
captures Bishop but then again simply d4
and after he captures the bishop
captures let's say night before you
attack the bishop now h3 and black would
be merciless here Queen to a6 with a
double attack on the bishop on f6 now
comes pawn captures on g2 Knight to f6
check King moves and now rook to g1 pawn
captures on f1 with check rook captures
now D captures on e3 and how do you how
do you defend this would would would
white Bishop is still slicing all the
way here the pawn is d2 + f2 squares
Queen to the Queen to d2 is a terrible
threat this would be checkmate so to
even consider going into this variation
you would have to you would have to find
this super engine defense with Bishop to
d7 blocking the Queen and allowing
allowing the King - maybe escape now
black can either either grab the piece
or black can continue the attack with
rook to b8 but either way white would
not have what a wife wouldn't enjoy
himself here
so after this Bishop to g4 sweedler
didn't really feel like going back so
instead this little swittel or played a
move that I'm sure shocked very shocked
as this is the first time Grisha even
saw this move he had this position on
the board but the moves wheeler played
gree she hasn't even considered and it's
one of those moves that the engine
doesn't like the engine does
even recommend this move but once you
play it the engine actually really likes
it so what do you think's wheeler played
here and deep down I'm sure you all know
what this wheeler played here it's it's
nothing for you to pause the video and
find it I'm just gonna show it to you
here sweedler played he captures on f6
so he grabbed that pawn he grabbed that
night and well while while grabbing it
he actually removed the defender of the
bishop on g4 so now actually Queen
captures on g4 would also be a threat
but on the other hand spoiler is also
offering his queen on d1 so what do you
do here there's a really no better move
than to capture the Queen so but should
capture some d1 now we have F captures
on g7 threatening G captures on f8 with
check King captures on g7 and now Bishop
captures on c5 you it'd be great you
already have three pieces for the Queen
it'd be great if you could grab another
one but unfortunately you can't if you
play King captures then you get to d4
black gets one piece back and on the
other hand even if you play Knight
captures on d1 now
d4 will not grab the knight and the
bishop now Queen to a5 check is coming
now your Bishop is under attack you're
also in check if you move the King you
lose the bishop and if you play Knight
to c3 back to guard bishop then d4 is
coming and black yet again wins the
piece so you cannot grab another piece
here so Bishop captures on c5 first we
have h3 now a threatening HP after son
g2 and now comes rope captures on d1
there's no good way to react to this h1
if you play something like this then
Bishop to f3 will be deadly now your
rook is under attack once you prevent
this Queen to h4 check is coming the
bishop is still slicing all the way here
after we block this then comes rock to
c8 and there is there's really there's
really no way to imagine wife could
survive this attack rookie rook is
coming to eight black black might even
give up the exchange here to continue
this attack
so after h3 rook captures and e1 it's
much much more important to grab that
bishop we have pawn captures and G 2
root 2 G 1 and now pawn captures on f1
temporarily there are two black Queens
on the board about of course King
captures Queen to h4 attacking the h2
pawn and now rook to g2 defending the
pawn rook F to d8 and now rook to d4 not
allowing this point to be pushed and
also attacking the Queen you don't
really you don't really have an option
of grabbing even more material here
would rook captures because after rook
captures Knight captures then your king
is well pretty naked on f1 and there are
two a3 undefended pieces here the two
bishops and the night and it would be
too easy for the black queen the pick up
to pick up at least one of those pieces
for example rook to c8 attacking the
bishop if you move the bishop then roof
to c1 will be very dangerous so you do
have to block this but now comes Queen
to e4 you attack the knight and there's
really no good square for the knight if
you move the knight to III then rook
captures simply removing the defender of
the night and if you play something like
rook to d2 to defend it then comes the
rook captures on c5 yet again pawn
captures and now Queen to be one check
I will pick up the bishop here after the
King moves can get to Queen captures on
b5 and now the Queen will be it will be
stronger than rook and the night so
after this rook F to the 8th
we have roof to d4 attacking the Queen
Queen to h5 and now rook to f4 here we
have d4 if you if you play something
like rook a to c8 then you get Bishop to
d4 check King moves and then after h4
it's it's very hard to decide what to do
with this Queen I mean you have a queen
for three pieces but the Queen is not
very active here Bishop to e2 e2 is
coming then the Queen doesn't really
have a good square the Queen would have
to go back and I mean there would be a
really passive position for gireesham so
after this rook to f4 move he decided to
play d4 so we have bishop captors and e4
would check and here he decides to give
up the exchange rook captures on d4 rook
captures on d4 and now rook to b8
attacking the bishop a for defending the
bishop and now immediately Queen to a
three dozen
give you anything every block we need
one check in moves there's really no
good way to continue this now so first
after this a four move good issue this
has to play a six now this Bishop has to
move and then rook capture some b2 will
definitely be an idea
so Bishop captures on a six we have
Queen to f3 check root of f2 now Queen
to h1 check King to f2 working three two
and now
since the bishop is no longer blocking
the B file rook captures on b2 with
check rook the d2 blocking and now Queen
to c1
if you captured here rook captures then
it's a queen against a rook and Knight
and the bishop white is definitely
better here it's hard to say if weif we
pull it off but probably white would
would win this so after work to d2 here
comes Queen to c1 now of course you
don't want to capture here if you
capture then Queen captures and your
knight is under attack you're under
check and there is no way to defend it
if you play King D three then you lose
the rook so you're gonna lose the night
here so after Queen to c1 we have a king
to d3 now the two rooks are attacking
the rook on b2 we have worked to b6
attacking the bishop and the Bishop to
c4 so as you can see now it's a Bishop
Knight and the rook against the Queen
but the king is on d3 it's it's hard to
say how which side can do anything here
rub the d6 check we have push up to d5
blocking a rope to d7 and now rook to f4
we have f5 rope to d4 and King to h6 h4
rook to c7 Knight Bishop to c4 blocking
the attack on the night Queen to f1
check
we have rook to e2 and now comes f4 the
threat of course is f3 this will attack
the pin piece and if black is able to to
make this happen then white will of
course be lost so King to see - this is
move 41 so time control has been reached
and here in this position Grisha played
f3 and it was in this position that the
players agreed to a draw
seems like like too early in the game to
actually
agree for a draw but but it was a such a
wild game and you know both of them
thought that oh man I'm gonna lose this
I'm gonna win this I'm gonna lose this
and now you have this after remove
grease Chuck offers a draw and a sailor
accepts the draw yeah it seems maybe it
may be premature but not really as the
rock is under attack you do have to move
it and then you realize okay the rook is
attacking the bishop and if I move the
rocket and the Queen will also be
attacking the bishop so obviously my
only move is look to e4 so both of my
rooks are guarding this bishop then of
course you see Quincy to check King
moves you're making room for the f1 you
put the F pawn and now of course White
has to prevent you from promoting the
pond to a queen this is done by rook to
f4 and now comes Luke captures on c4
removing the defender of the f1 square
rock captures and now you promote your
pawn to Queen rook captures Queen
captures so this is the position both
wheeler and Grisha saw when they agree
to a draw in that position and here it's
it's a rook and Knight and and up and
the past a point against the Queen but
the king is bear on b3 and there is no
way to escape checks from the black
queen so even if you try to win this
with white let's say you put a pawn the
Queen will simply position herself and
after you start you know escorting the
pawn it will be impossible to stop all
the checks for example Queen f8 check
you block Queen back to a4 check King
moves forward Queen to be a check King
moves back then comes Queen f4 again
came to b3 again you go Queen to be a to
check and if you try something like King
to a3 now again Queen to f4 not allowing
him to go any further and here if you if
you try to pull the pawn then comes
Queen b6 pinning the rook and also
attacking the point you have to defend
the King here and then Queen captures
you lose the passed pawn and now it's
it's it's a clear draw or or maybe black
can even you know trick white into
winning this but okay after this F no
even before this after f3 was played
yeah in this position two players agree
to a draw and
what I mean water draw it was so I
really I really wanted to show you this
game because a lot of you might not even
see it because you know when you see a
result as a draw then you're you're not
even interested in checking the game but
I mean what a game first that prepared
sacrifice Knight captures on c4 by Glee
shook and then sailor countering it here
with wood it captures on f6 that's
simply amazing what a move that was so
yeah I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Derrick angling Danny
McCullough david guzman ruiz and hans of
RL for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here i think all for
watching and i will see you soon
what with another nice video from round
9 of the 2013 candidates tournament
thank you all and I'll see you soon